What is software design? Software design is the process of
building a program while satisfying the program's functional requirements and
not violating any of its non-functional constraints. This is going to turn out
to be a question of trade offs. How do you trade off between performance and
resource consumption, for example? Software design is normally broken into two
different phases, architectural design and detail design. Architectural design
is the process of carving up the programs into components and
assigning responsibilities for aspects of behavior to each component and talking
about how the components are going to interact with each other. We're going to
spend a great deal of time in this course talking about architectural design.
Detail design is the process of dealing with the individual components.
Particularly, with respect to their data structures and their algorithms.
Let's look for a minute at some of the aspects of detail design.